de la vie des militaires et des
spécialistes il est d'une efficacité
redoutable sur le terrain le léopard 2
un char lourd de fabrication allemande
dédiée au combat un engin de 60 tonnes
qui peut atteindre les 70 km/h et avec
une autonomie de 450 km ces
caractéristiques techniques comme son
équipement de vision nocturne et son
efficacité contre les mines et les
lance-roquettes lui Val d’être très
convoité par les combattants ukrainiens
ont un équipement de grande qualité mais
avant tout ils offrent une meilleure
protection avec plus de blindage leur
rôle est crucial pour notre survie
bien sûr que c'est tant que seraient
très important pour nous mais il
faudrait former les équipes à leur
utilisation sont nécessaires mais très
compliqué des tanks plus techniques et
qui pourrait jouer un rôle crucial dans
cette guerre
à l'heure où Kiev temps de reconquérir
son territoire avec un armement
vieillissant l'armée ukrainienne en est
bien consciente elle a d'ailleurs fait
pression sur les chancelles risques
occidentales ces derniers mois pour lui
livrer du matériel de pointes à l'image
des chars Léo par deux construit en
série à partir de la fin des années 70
et aujourd'hui adopté par une douzaine
de nations européennes selon des
estimations environ 3500 exemplaires de
ce blindé ont été produits des pays
comme la Grèce l'Espagne et la Turquie
en possède chacun plus de 300 services
de son côté l'Ukraine affirme qu'il lui
faudrait 300 chars au total pour mener
une opération militaire d'ampleur contre
les forces russes